[Applaudissements]
la boue je me suis un peu entraîné c'est
vrai mais je tiens à préciser que le
tour a été tenté plusieurs fois dans les
plus grand cabaret du monde qui n'ont
jamais réussi les plus grands s'y sont
essayés houdini compréhensible ça n'a
jamais marché
oui je me lance je ne sais pas ce que ça
va donner ces deux accessoires qui sont
juste en dessous deux accessions qui ont
été gentiment offert par tata benhaim
qui n'est pas là ce soir il ya blood
beauté il m'a donné deux deux charmants
foulard comme ça vendue au modeste prix
les 87 euros sur le blog de tête la bd
tout simplement essayé de faire des pas
de ça c'est pas le tour de magie je vous
préviens tout de suite je fais un noeud
juste entre les deux c'est déjà ce nom
c'est pas le tout mais pas rigolé après
je vois rigoler parce que franchement
voilà une fois que j'ai fait le tour je
mets la main le noeud à l'intérieur de
mon poids comme ça maintenant je vais
avoir besoin d'une assistante avec si
possible un corps un peu qu'il fasse
rêver des téléspectateurs atteignant de
la vie ludivine et je te confie ce
foulard je te bouffer se fout là je n'ai
pas que jamais rien tu va le mettre dans
la profondeur de tombeaux des copains
évidemment jean michaud ils sont en
sécurité
personne ne plus y accéder et à pois
pour montrer qu a pas de triche pour toi
la sécurité ça passe par l'esa mais non
mais non c'est pas ça mais ça reste
dissuasion et de l'intérieur de ton et
généreux l'enfance le plus possible
jusqu'au qui est pas de nous déclasser
jean-michel pas de me déplacer à carla
non mais qui pour la conseiller et après
tu le tiens bien en dessous au plus sans
règles sans suffisamment ses canettes
ouakam attends tu le tiens effet demain
comme ça tu mettais demain en dessous
comme ça pour bien montrer qu'on tire
pas trop de souci non j'ai rien faire là
voilà voilà maintenant que c'était
maintenant j'ai besoin nous le petit
accessoire que juni mine que ludivine
map assez vite et j'en tire il voulait
un petit rescapé défouloir rouge comme
ça on va vous le faire disparaître mais
ça c'est de ces l'enfance de l'art pour
tous les magiciens et ainsi supplique le
met un peu dans mon pouce comme ça je
rentre bien vouloir la blague du mec a
pas de pousser un peu comme les cafés
aof ipsos commandé alors que ça peut
compliquer à une bagarre n'est pas trop
quand même parce que la gestion de
centre a le mérite des gens qui voyagent
autres biens de nouvelles versions de
ses dires surtout ce soit à son
attention attention d'associations
[Applaudissements]
ouais apparu ce petit mouchoir rouge
n'est pas par terre la facilité sa ce
régime soit à l'intérieur d'une femme
qu'on a joué à l'avancé et n étant pas
mon genre voilà celle il le sait voilà
je m'approche je ne fais rien et je vais
faire là le clou du spectacle jamais été
réussi mais je pense que peut-être la
tension attention au matap et à tous un
deux trois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'avais commencé un bébé s'appelle le
talent tout simplement